Welcome to A.B. Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Welcome back to A.B. Testing.
I'm Alan.
Brent isn't here.
He is installing an extensive amount of LED and smart lighting in Satya's home
today.
We hope to have him back next week.
It should be a lot of fun.
Instead, I had the great pleasure of coming across someone online in the last year and
then we got a chance to take a walk around Seattle and talk and talk and thought, man,
it should be recorded.
So today that's happening.
So on the show today is Lana Veganova.
Lana, say hi.
Hello, everybody.
Hi, Alan.
Nice to see you again.
It's a pleasure.
Thank you for having me on.
I'm glad to have you here.
We had such an interesting talk and the talk was kind of to see if, like, can we get along
for a podcast to maybe two and we can.
And so many interesting stories and it was two months ago and I'm maybe getting older
and I forgot what most of them were.
But I remember the gist of them and yeah.
And I thought it would be fun today.
I think there's some really interesting projects Lana is working on and has worked
on and we'll get to those.
I think maybe the place to start and there will be tangents because we do that on this
show.
Actually, the first tangent is this is really cool.
I'm sure you've recognized this and just haven't said anything yet, but our names
are anagrams of each other.
I wanted to lead with that, but I wanted you to keep that that entrance into the
convo is your privilege.
Get out of my head.
I won't.
You invited me.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, Lana, you have a just I kind of want your origin story like I think it's really
interesting your life and your journey into tech and all that.
So I won't ask for like, you know, where you were born or anything.
Just tell you I would like to talk about where you came from and where you are and
what that journey has been like to start off with.
Right.
Well, as usual, the normal people start at the beginning.
So just before we actually hit the record on the path cast, I was saying that I
started early in the labor market.
I'm one of those folks that since childhood is overly ambitious, I guess,
have been have been super busy.
I like to keep my hands and my frontal cortex plugged in and at work and
constantly pumping through some electromagnetic energy.
That's what keeps my heart driving.
And I put that feeling into life in general and into my professional career as
well, because typically I think what drives me is doing what I like to be
doing while obviously earning the bread and butter and bacon, because, you
know that this is the world and, you know, we have to bring the bread to
the table.
So since early on, I graduated really early from high school in a country
called Uzbekistan, which is in Central Asia, part of the post Soviet Union
territory. So by the accent, you can tell that I wasn't probably born and
raised in the States.
And that's why I do want to add interject because one of my best
friends is from Uzbekistan.
Yes, and that is so exciting, isn't that wild?
And Seattle has Tashkent Park and Tashkent is in Uzbekistan and a sister
city to Seattle.
So it's just interesting and serendipitous.
The other thing is a little bit of trivia, Uzbekistan is one of two
double landlocked countries in the world, meaning it's landlocked and
every country it touches, it's also landlocked.
Right. It's one of the rare extremely continental places, which
impacts, I think, the climate, obviously, people's mentalities.
But one of the most beautiful things about the country where I was
raised is the hospitality and the warmth of the people.
I am myself of many mixed origins.
So by default, I think even if I want to, I cannot discriminate
against anything or anyone that is against my DNA code.
Just happened to be so.
And the country I grew up in is very diverse, very warm,
very in terms of culture, cuisine.
It's also sort of very ancient.
It's one of the places where I think the temples in places like
Somerkand, Kiva, Tashkent, the touristy people who like exotic
places may be familiar with those.
Like that's the place where some ancient temples that are like
two, two and a half thousand years old are located.
So it's a very culturally rich place.
However, just like graduating high school on time wasn't an option for me.
Graduating college also wasn't.
So I, I expedited that.
I took a bigger load and graduated soon in order basically to leave
for the United States, because I also was building since early teens,
a career at the United Embassy.
I was working in various administrative and financial positions there.
So before I even hit 18, I was already lending in Los Angeles.
Wow.
One of those stories where you have like five and a half dollars in your pocket,
not knowing where to go and just building it all up from scratch.
Nobody understood why I did it.
It seems like I may have had it really good back at home,
but never enough for me.
So got to deal with that.
Ended up in L.A.
As a typical immigrant, went through all kind of, you know, jobs just to survive.
And then I ended up in the actuarial field in a company,
in a consulting firm that serves as insurance companies.
So before I even dove in tech and we are getting there,
hopefully within 60 seconds.
We don't have time limits on AB testing.
Tell your story. I think this is just so fascinating to me.
I love the listeners know that like, and you know this,
but I came from a music background from the way in the tech.
I love the diversity of backgrounds,
people that fire in the way in the tech and are really good at it.
So please continue.
Yeah. So I was also an audible in the actuarial field.
I was doing mostly regulatory compliance work, was good at it,
but also was sort of a misfit there.
I think I'm a misfit everywhere.
And that's why I'm welcome everywhere as well.
There are pluses and minuses to being myself.
It's not always easy.
I want to stop on that sentence because I think that about myself a lot.
There are pluses and minuses to being myself because I'm,
I'm, I'm my very own particular cup of tea.
I'm an acquired taste.
I give reclamers to everyone, you know,
I try to be a nice person, but, you know,
living life is one thing, but truly being yourself is a full time job.
To me, it's it's a 24 seven thing.
And it's probably my primary job before any academia,
collegiate work or professional career work comes into place.
Because you may be picking up on a pattern.
I was born with a brain that's never sort of
now at rest.
And it keeps it's a good thing and a bad thing.
It's a gift and a curse.
It keeps driving me forward.
And it landed me in the tech industry after I spent,
you know, was playing numbers in finance, in fintech, actuarial stuff.
Basically, I realized a few years ago that again,
probably not a good thing.
Whatever I was doing wasn't sufficient enough.
And I I would grow it and I didn't want to stay where I was.
So I found new challenges.
I'm also very good at that.
My brain and I are very close neighbors,
but it really puts me through through through trips sometimes.
Yeah, I can relate.
Yeah, you you come from a rather you have creative,
I think not necessarily really hard,
but more on the soft side type of experience and skills, I'm sure.
Those are and to be fair, those are learned traits.
I've had to learn to slow my brain down and not.
I still work on this.
If I let my brain go on natural rhythm, I will interrupt.
I would be interrupting all the time.
Oh, I want to say this. I want to say that.
So this is this is self control.
I yeah, sometimes I just have to take a breath and slow down.
Yeah, I've been working on terminology with myself,
like basically my brain and I are in constant negotiation.
I think we have settled on not on necessarily self control,
quote unquote, but on self regulation as healthy as possible.
It comes with having your own
and building your own strong boundaries before you even impose them
or on anything or anyone around you.
And seeing those boundaries within yourself and projecting outward
is, I think, the most difficult job of my lifetime.
With I think mobile automation comes second.
Yeah. And we're going to get to that in a minute.
I've been thinking a lot just while we're talking about our relations
with our brains and how they work.
I've been thinking a lot about that recently.
And I yeah, my brain, sometimes it brains really well.
May I ask you if I ask you, who is the king in the castle?
Who owns you? Who are you?
Is it you or your brain?
It's the brain. It's the brain.
The brain. Well, I'm the boss.
The brain doesn't listen, I think.
The brain does what it wants.
Mischievous child.
Yeah, the brain is a mischievous child.
I am in control, but the brain, like it will like it's like,
dude, what are you doing?
Chill or I'll notice like patterns of like, why am I?
I spend a lot of time thinking about why I do things.
This is something I learned.
I've been working on a lot and a lot recently, too, is understanding
what's going on in my head that when I make decisions,
when I decide to do something, when I
you know, I'll just say when I make a decision,
kind of I tend to kind of analyzing why I'm trying to understand.
I'm you know, I've been around the planet a few times.
I finally to a point where I'm
I spend a lot of time lately, at least
trying to figure out why my brain does what it does,
the good and the bad.
It's just it's just fascinating.
Plus theories on that official scientific go on.
No, that's it. That's it.
I'm just trying to figure myself out while I
learn to grow up a little bit.
Yes, I think
the hardest thing is actually aligning the speed
at which I myself and I can move compared to the speed of my brain.
It is definitely an incredible intelligent machine
that has evolutionally, I don't know, been developing
layer by layer if we if we start talking
neural nets, neurons, which is a very, I think, hot topic.
It has been obviously with AI, because if you read into it,
AI has been around for like 70 years.
But recently, it people start actually thinking about it,
like in the kitchens and the households, you know,
not only in the super secret AI labs where they have frontier models,
you know, tuning and training those.
But before I understand even AI, which is a part,
I think a mandatory part of any of anyone of any tech job these days,
whether you're developing, testing, managing, whatever the hell you do.
Not even in tech.
AI is a mandatory essential part of any knowledge work.
Yeah, I myself am right now
feeling the need to integrate that into my workflow and part of
like why I'm constantly learning new tools along the way.
But before, you know, we even get to neural nets like my eternal daily job
is always understanding what's crackling inside of those.
You know, what are those axons doing?
Because if you allow me a little
little tangent for a minute.
We love tangents and a tangent audio effect.
I don't have one anyway. Go on.
All right. So in general, I think
you may be familiar that I'm acquainted with Jason Arban,
one of the more prolific
figures in the AI tech industry these days,
especially for the automation test engineers.
So him and I talked recently and I told them, you know,
like I hear that electric electric electricity
like crackling in my brain.
The closest definition of that that I found and the way it sounds.
Well, I've definitely determined I'm a little bit synesthetic,
at least a little bit.
So that kind of layers a lot into the percept perceptron, so to speak.
And the closest definition of what it might be is actually Tom York
from Radiohead saying that many, many years ago,
like probably at least 20 years ago and not in a song,
but somewhere in an interview.
And if you're familiar, he's like not too big on interviews at all.
Private person.
And whatever he says, something like I listen in, to be honest,
even if he's shalundering and fooling around, these are extreme
level of like true ingenue on this on this planet.
Even if he's a musician, he's so tuned in and do the universe.
I take that.
I take that comment personally, even though he's a musician,
like musicians are less.
What do you mean?
Oh, I actually it is a personal insecurity and defencibility
because I do like the creative.
I think creativity is under the creative force
is what drives the universe and us as its participants.
Please do not get offended.
I'm teasing. I'm not offended.
I'm going to cry.
I'm going to call you out on that stuff and intentions.
I swear.
The thing is that I myself, if it turns, if I'm
sending that trajectory and that factor onto you, forgive me.
It's my personal thing.
Subjectively, I think that being creative is
is being the force of nature by default.
However, since I'm a late
arrival into the tech industry, like I transitioned rather late
in my career, relatively speaking, and I have about
like seven years in tech, in IT, in experience,
which is not sufficient, but it is just enough where I have enough
of the non-primary work creative activities
where I get entirely engulfed into those.
It's a true joy and pleasure for me to actually be making something,
creating something, seeing the results.
I've been like that since the childhood.
If you haven't picked up the trace, the thread there of the pattern.
And so forgive me, like truly, even even even if for a second there,
it did sound offensive because as an
but by day, I do my typical as dating test automation work.
By night, I'm the creative and I am proud of it.
I cherish it, but I cherish it to the degree.
And because to a large degree, many tech people,
let's say 90 percent of IT people are
a bit hard headed and hard skilled, not necessarily soft skilled.
And it is also an almost an entirely daily challenge.
We're getting through the thickets communicatively with people in IT.
Whereas like sometimes I find myself like I'm child free,
but I feel sometimes like that person like that,
you know, irate mother who says, child, use your words.
You think with all the layoffs in tech,
can we be more selective and lay off the people
that don't have any interpersonal skills?
Let's say I've been frustrated in the tech field
with a with a with a caliber of of lack
of empathy, creativity, like there is this big drive around engineers.
And you know what? I'm a learned engineer.
So if anyone wants to throw a stone and, you know, over my fence, be my guest.
I dare you, in fact, connect with me.
But as you OK, I'll wrap this up.
As you can tell, I can be actually super passionate
and defensive of any creative inkling in anyone.
And I do it almost like naturally by default, unlike that.
But I also intentionally do that almost every day, whatever it takes.
Write, draw, embroider, cook your food from scratch.
Like, you know, what's creative?
Try making your your sour dough from scratch
and baking a good bread.
I also dare you that that's not I just made one two days ago.
Awesome. So you get the gist, right?
I get the gist. I love cooking.
It's I really enjoy it.
And I'm just teasing you.
Do we ever get back to Tom Morello?
Oh, no, we didn't, did we?
Because I gave you shit about the about about the musician thing.
He said something, he said, even though he's a musician.
And I said, wait a minute, what's wrong with musicians?
Right, right, right.
So that was about Tom York, who told the electric buzz in the brain.
You see, I go in tangent times five.
Disclaimer, disclaimer.
So, yeah, I'm one of those weird people who constantly hears electric
buzz and crackling in my brain.
And to a degree, I can actually detect what it means and where it's going.
And I talked to Jason Arvin recently about that.
And I'm like, you know, I'm a little like
not, quote unquote, a normie in like the typical IT field.
So I got a confession to make about this electrical crackling
because we talk about AI, neural nets.
And I I try not to anthropomorphize things,
but I constantly draw connections because I do know that,
you know, artificial neural nets are trying to imitate the human brain,
the most complex creation in the in the universe.
So, yeah, I had a very awkward confession to Jason Arvin
even recently about having some hearing some electrical crackling in my brain.
And Tom York, to my defense, said that he hears it 24 seven as a musician.
So a musician is a plus in this statement, in this argument,
because he has some sort of open
perceptive like things in him or in his brain
and his maybe hearing apparatus, whatever it is.
But he himself is capable of being a musical tool.
That is also where I tell not just play a tool, but be a tool with voice.
And he's the kind of guy who like is constantly
he says he drives.
He said it drove him insane that he constantly hears this
like what he calls it, like electric fridge buzz in the background.
Hmm. So that's my defense line.
I think you did say something else in there about like
noticing it there.
And here what you said, but you you know it's there and you notice it
and you know why you're you're learning what the buzz means.
I I am a good transcriber of my own thoughts.
The only regret I have is that I don't have a brain
powerful enough of synchronous interpretation.
You know, those guys who do translations on like at the UN.
Yeah. And diplomatic.
To hear and speak at almost the same time and listening to what's coming next.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'm only saying that because I sort of started my very early
tender teenage career in like the diplomatic field.
So I sort of dove into that and I had to also communicatively that help.
Because when when you're not even 16 and you're sitting at round
diplomatic tables, even on the sidelines and observing, it really
grows you up real quick.
You know, you learn a lot.
And so you do learn to notice what's happening on the foreground
and what's happening in the background and everything in the spaces in between.
And like I said, it's like I noticed that brain is a beautiful thing.
I just said, like, I wish it were even more powerful sometimes,
like those with those synchronous translators where one slip up
may cost a nuclear war, you know, literally in.
And they they go into some weird state of mind
where they are semi conscious as some sort of as a washed up state of mind
where they are not even aware of what they're doing.
They're just doing it.
And when they clock out, when they walk out of that
intense interpretation, like community or communication room,
they don't even remember what they did like.
They did like just to say that
I know I know that my brain is a powerful machine.
There are so many instances of it.
Yeah. And I I I hope I will keep on going in this tech industry
because you've noticed a pattern that I sit around maybe for a few years
and then I I shift gears.
So far, though, it is holding me around.
I'm really happy about the engineering aspect
because I'm a quick learner and I'm a full board engineer,
you know, even a few years into the tech.
I do struggle with people, though.
That's something that I need to learn.
People is the hard part.
And I've spent a lot of time working on that.
I want to talk a little bit about the buzz and a framework
and then how it's all going to segue together in my head.
So I had a different kind of buzz.
I think I don't think it's the same, but but they're related.
When I was hiking last summer,
I was just figuring out a lot of stuff about myself.
And what I noticed is at one point,
the but I, you know, the refrigerator,
you don't know it's on until it's off.
You go, it's quiet.
My brain got quiet.
I thought it was just this wonderful feeling of like
the buzz wasn't there anymore.
And what that allowed me to do was to pay attention
when the buzz comes back and then try and identify what it is.
And it could be ideas.
It could just be distractions.
It could be stress.
It could be whatever.
But I recognize a lot more now when the buzz is there
because I knew what it was like when it wasn't there
finally for the first time in, you know, decades.
So my buzz is a little different.
I think your buzz is more of, you know,
ideas and inventions, maybe.
And it and I could be wrong.
Because I'll start on another tangent of let's discuss
the difference or similarities between inventions and discoveries.
And I'm going to go on that thing.
Are we really inventors or are we just is there anything new under the sun?
I'll shut up. Keep going.
And this is maybe worth talking about.
So I'm a fan of this framework from Pat Lynch.
You only call the working genius.
It's just yet another one of these.
What work do you enjoy or not like?
And it says for any project that needs to get done, it starts with wonder.
You wonder about the possibilities.
Then there's the invention phase.
And then there's the discernment phase to ask questions around,
you know, product market fit, viability, et cetera.
Then there's galvanizing,
which is getting the whole team to work together to solve this thing.
And then there's enablement, giving people the support or education
they need to get the job done.
And then tenacity just to carry it across the finish line.
And what Lencioni says, and I believe this based on myself, is any
anybody can do all six of those.
But generally, there's two that really give you energy,
two that drain the crap out of you,
and two that are sort of in the middle there.
And you seem like and it.
I think you live on the I don't know where you live on that.
You sound like a wonder.
Maybe a discern or two.
You could be a wonder or discerner, a wonder or inventor discerner.
I'm not quite sure yet with you, but I think
from what I hear you say, your buzz comes from.
I think it's coming from the first half of that.
I don't know for sure.
It's from Tom York's fridge.
Maybe it's from Tom York's fridge.
So I I live in the middle of that.
I like to discern and galvanize.
I will ask people questions about things.
And I'm good at getting people to rally around
and try and get the change done.
I don't think I don't think those are your two geniuses.
Discernment, maybe possibly, possibly.
But, you know, in terms of what to do with it in general,
unfamiliar with the feeling of turning it off, actually,
sometimes even consciously, so to speak,
because I'm also aware of, you know, at least three level
of three levels of.
I hate to sound woke like Elon Musk, but awareness.
Now, I don't even know.
I don't even know who that is.
Right. Right.
Redacted.
I don't edit for a stuck with it.
So too bad.
I I do want to touch on.
Do we invent or do we just discover?
Yes. And I like I can take it from the music perspective.
You could say that.
I mean, we get new music all the time, and that music is
derivative in some way from music that's been created before.
So we just discovered a new way to put it together.
You know, when a certain musician
who's really made a lot of his fans angry,
I won't even mention his name had a court case
because one of the songs was it was infringing and he played in court.
He just showed that so many pop songs follow the exact same court sequence.
That's a that's pretty well known.
It's like how you put together the words.
It's a little bit of difference.
But are people discovering new songs or they inventing new songs?
When we go to technology, are we discovering or inventing?
We're just kind of finding new ways to put things together.
I think it's a fine line and maybe they're the same thing.
And we can talk more about that.
But you have done some you can tell me whether it's discovery
or invention recently, and you're working on a project
that I would love to talk about some more and our listeners
would love to talk about some more.
I'm tell me I'm going to I'll let you tell the story.
So you're you're making a new thing.
You know what I'm talking about?
How did that where did the where did the idea come from?
Kind of talk about your work through,
I guess, with hugs and maybe start from there and kind of where you are now
and this cool thing you're working on there.
That's the big mystery intro.
I'll let you unravel the mystery into reality.
All right. So here we come at the moment.
And that's something you wear.
I don't know if I myself or my brain surprised me with it went ahead
and concocted a thing called Vibium, a mobium,
a I think heavily inspired by vibium.
If anyone knows testing or automation
and has been there for at least few years,
I think most of those people have heard the name of Jason Huggins.
He is the guy who has been out there for 20 plus years.
We know him for giving us selenium,
co-creating Appium for mobile.
And now he is hard at it, building vibium.
And basically, I would say the best way to represent it,
it's it's it would be too crude to call it selenium with AI.
But it is his creation,
which is targeted more at agentic experience
rather than developer experience.
And the differentiator there for a year has been that,
let's say, playwright is has also really well equipped
for the new with the new AI features
for the new AI related challenges.
However, vibium has all of that kind of all of those things
that came along wrapped in from the get go and one same binary.
And I have been following vibium really closely
because I sort of happened to get a chance to also cross paths
with Jason Huggins before even vibium happened,
actually right before.
There was about a year and a half ago,
I ended up presenting Appium at Microsoft Reactor.
And slightly later, per request of Mr. Huggins,
I sort of became I think there is no official term,
but an unofficial semi autonomous kind of proxy
on his behalf to, if needed,
sort of explain or publicize anything that he's been doing.
And just to reemphasize about a year and a half ago,
vibium still wasn't really a thing.
I think it was already boiling up like concocting in his brain
and he may have been talking to some investors.
But in addition to Appium, for his request,
I ended up presenting Valet, his proprietary tapster product,
which is aimed at mobile automation with robots basically.
And then that kind of came and went and vibium arrived.
I think, you know, I'm not involved
in the vibium business side of things, so to speak.
I'm a complete outsider, but I'm an active cheerleader
and participant of the development
and engineering effort that got vested into the product,
because I am personally and very selfishly concerned
about having a legit, fast, AI-adapted,
AI-native test automation product in the nearest few years.
There are plenty of tools,
but I have this silly, naive belief in Hugs' products
simply because when I arrived in the tech industry,
transitioned from fintech and his tools are the ones,
the open source ones are the ones
that actually made my work possible.
Not only could I do my actual work
and accomplish results and keep moving in my career,
that is actually a rather well-paid job,
surprisingly to me,
because, you know, I just wasn't aware of it before.
So I have the deepest, outmost respect to this man
for everything he has given the industry.
I had to learn it really fast in a couple of years
in a very compacted manner,
where I both kind of learned Selenium Classic
and Selenium WebDriver By Die, as well as Appium,
and I wrote profusely and intensely about that
on various publishing platforms.
So the natural transition for me
was to actually focus on Vibium,
starting as of about a year ago.
As you may know, actually, where we met,
there is a Discord channel for Vibium
that Hugs has opened up for the interested followers,
and I got so interested in Vibium
that I was just sort of cheerleading it along
and ended up being a Vibium memer at some point.
Also sort of a title that I think Hugs gave himself to me.
I wasn't really asking for it.
So about nine or eight years ago, months ago,
on the Vibium Discord channel,
I started writing Vibium-themed songs,
generating all sorts of memes, sharing experiments.
So creatively, I've been sort of supporting Vibium
semi-autonomously. It's a weird thing.
But my Vibium-themed song ended up on Hugs's,
what is it called, player.vibium.dev
or something like that, basically,
is a trace recorder player where you could hit a button
and listen to the song I made with AI.
It is the weirdest credit I claim,
and I don't know how to feel about it,
but I'll let it go.
I can relate to that feeling.
Yeah, so I'm not going to repeat myself,
but at some point, that wasn't enough, as usual.
We're noticing a theme.
Right, pattern recognition.
And I couldn't help myself get involved,
but get involved technically.
So about, I think it's been four or six months now
that I took Vibium and started,
just my thing, and started exercising it
and preparing and analyzing it and diagnosing it
like no one would, I would say, in terms of...
I treated it as an astronaut that's about to launch into space,
and it had to be in a tip-top shape,
you know, because the reality is that playwright
and that field is the incumbent right now,
and it is not the whole thing about even having Vibium
is that playwright is not entirely open source,
and anyone who's involved in the W3C work
or WebDriver work or anything like that,
they're all big proponents of the open standards,
which I also cheer for,
but basically, Vibium has been,
or I'll rephrase it,
and he can shoot me for it later if he wants.
I think Hugs is reclaiming his automation throne
in our niche, in our testing automation niche.
I believe in that effort as a human,
and I don't think I can justify it logically.
I did think about it,
like what even I find attractive about it
as a person and as a professional.
Like I said, anyone can shoot me later for what I said,
but I'm saying it.
First, I thought Hugs is a type of...
No one is gonna argue
that he's an extremely intelligent person,
an extremely skilled and crafty engineer and tool-smith.
That's what I know about him,
just looking from outside in,
but also I had this undeniable feeling for a while
that what is it about this person
and the things that he makes?
It's not about a product.
It's about the people that stand behind it.
Who makes it?
Where is this originator?
What is the origin source?
Pardon.
The original source is the creator,
which is Jason Huggins in this regard,
and I have respected and admired him
and what he does by default for years,
and I feel like I had no option
but to buy into this idea.
I owed it to myself.
First, it was feeling like,
oh, this guy has the Midas gift, right?
Whatever he touches turns into gold,
but we all know how Midas ended,
so maybe it's not the bestest idea for him
or the thing to be.
And I'll say a very radical
and a very personal thing right now,
but I think many people feel the same way around him
and his universe, I would say,
and the things that he makes.
I don't think I made a conclusion for myself
that it's not a Midas thing.
It is personal.
It is a very difficult thing to admit.
I am child-free.
I am religion-free.
I'm trying to be as a free-willed person as possible,
but there is one undeniable thing on this planet
is that some people are just plugged
into some universal creative sockets
that we don't see, we are not able to do.
So I think this guy, Hagenz, is not a Midas.
He is more like a prophet
in the task automation industry.
And this is a super big word.
Like I said, shoot me for it now or later.
I'm okay with it.
I'll survive.
But to me, it is personal
because even Hagenz's words,
when you try to prove anything,
what proves it is the working code,
and he is capable of that.
Anytime he has an idea, he just concocts something.
Nobody, like somehow,
like I don't even understand
how the wiring in his brain works,
but that's what's fascinating to me personally.
So I believe in him as a creator,
as an engineer,
as an engineer.
And I'm very maybe biased and subjective in that regard
because if there are any niche prophets, he is it.
And that's why I'm following the man.
I'm respecting the man and everything that he makes.
And the reality that the very crude,
realistic, practical reality
is that just understanding,
being a late arrival in IT,
understanding that open source is a thing,
that it exists and you can just download it
and get things done, automate things.
That was a big surprise to me.
And where those tools came from is this man,
the tools that I used.
And so I have been exercising Vibium
for at least half a year very intensely
on all of its surfaces.
The non-deterministic layer
with the TUI or CLI interface plus MCP
for more standardized protocolized tool calling.
And in addition to that,
the deterministic more of the quote unquote
old school language bindings or libraries
of which he has, how many does he have?
Three now, JavaScript, Java, Python,
plus CLI plus MCP on the agentic side.
So I've been exercising the five surfaces
for about half a year.
And I've also been trying to catch up with time
and post enough about it on social media
about the terrible bugs that I've been finding
and filing and enhancements that I've been proposing.
Basically from my pitch,
Vibium introduced Shadow DOM support
on all their clients recently.
And it's a bit of a bragging minute here for me.
About a month ago,
I ran basically whatever I do, I run it.
I put it through purgatory.
Like my test has to serve any,
I've done thousand tests for Vibium by now.
And every single one has been run
at least a hundred or a thousand times.
So we are talking about the degrees of freedom.
I wanted to say, no, not really.
The magnitude of what I've been doing
with Vibium behind the scenes.
I don't think even Huggins himself realizes.
The unfortunate or fortunate outcome
is that I ended up reporting
a lot of fixes and enhancements.
And in that regard, just being so involved
and plugged in into Vibium
without being an official Vibium developer even.
Like I said, I'm like a semi-autonomous outsider
who's just a big fan, who's a very engaged fan.
Even last week, I filed like a couple more bugs.
But I think the one that I'm,
the enhancement that I'm proud of
is running the CLI surface of Vibium so many times
that I am measuring everything so intensely
that I realized that we could make the CLI surface
which is already super fast compared to even MCP.
And anyone who works with that,
like even on Playwright, they have that.
They have their own CLI surface and MCP surface
and many automation tools
like even the mobile ones do these days.
So even the fast surface,
the fastest agentic surface CLI,
I made it a few times faster
just by measuring what could be surgically removed
from the programmatic flow and reattached
so that again, making the faster surface even faster.
That's, I take that credit.
Hugs asked to file it as an enhancement.
They accepted it.
They emerged it in.
I'm super happy.
However, the side effects of that involvement to Vibium,
right, is that now in addition to Vibium.
It's like it wasn't enough.
It wasn't enough.
It ain't enough.
So the story goes that Lana got bored last weekend.
She could not find her place in her own home.
I was feeling like my brain is trying to go
into some weird limbo state
and I had to do something extreme,
something super actionable, something real
to purge that thing outside of my frontal cortex.
And I created Mobium, surprise, surprise.
I'm not sure how anyone feels about it these days.
It's a super spanking fresh new brand new thing
that I just concocted a few days ago
and have had a sleepless week
of basically chiseling it out
like a statue out of marble, you know,
dot by dot, layer by layer.
But I got so excited about Vibium
that I decided to make and create its mobile analog,
so to speak, but also the open source analog
just like Vibium.
So long story short is like,
I admire and follow this creator man
who makes amazing products in my mind, right?
You can argue with that, but in my subjective universe
and my subjective career,
to the point where I think it's not necessarily him,
him and many other things and myself have inspired,
got inspired to concoct a new,
you could call it a new Appium, so to speak.
I won't be plugging it too much right now.
I'm super happy because there are some really mature
Appium maintainers and developers
and a couple of other folks that already got interested
and they wanna test it for me.
And I'm super excited because to be honest,
to be doing all this work,
you gotta have some tokens in your pocket.
And if anyone can spend their free tokens
or non-free tokens on just testing my product
and running it, I'm all in.
But if not, I'll survive again.
I'm one of those people.
I ask, but I'll still survive if I don't get.
So that's basically where I stand right now
as an automator, as a tester,
growing aggressively and intentionally
into becoming an AI native engineer.
And a part of it is not just picking up what someone made
but also going ahead and making something for myself,
which I already find useful
because I think we'll need another interview
about the challenges of mobile testing.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's too hard, don't do it.
But this is the fun part about what we're seeing now
with AI is a lot of the things we've never done before
because they were too hard or they take too much time
are now becoming possible.
Yes.
And yeah, mobile automation has been a mess
for a long time.
So I'm excited about your product.
And I'm gonna go on a limb and say
that you did not discover, you invented
and a lot of invention is just putting the pieces together.
I'm gonna plug this book from Steven Johnson called
Where Good Ideas Come From.
And there's patterns that just kind of that will,
inventions come, they don't really come,
very few just come out of the blue.
It's when connections happen.
But when the right circumstances are suddenly available
for this new idea to come forth.
So what you did was invent.
You invented a, what would I call it?
It's a mobile testing framework
using all the goodness of AI.
I don't wanna try and give it a fancy like AI forward,
blah, blah, blah, AI first.
I don't know.
Yeah, you know, I'm neutral.
It's a thing.
It's like air now, we gotta breathe it.
And there is no point arguing if it's good or bad.
Period.
It's there and I'm guessing it's going to be useful
and useful is generally good.
It is, you know, cause two years ago,
I had to budget for mobile developers,
especially for native mobile developers
to concoct me a react native app.
Like yesterday, it took me five minutes.
I have a full blown production ready mobile app.
I know it's ridiculous.
On both for both Android and iOS,
which I'm already building an option
for it to be extensible for like Flutter or Roku TV,
anything like mobile,
anything non-desktop on non-laptop,
anything like basically anything.
We'll see where it goes.
I'm excited, a little scared, a little nervous,
but that's a part of that.
Like you said, maybe discovery or innovation process.
I'll take your opinion and position on what I did,
but I personally, am I still not sure
what discovery or invention is?
Like, in fact, I know so much about it
that it becomes blurry.
Well, I think it may not matter.
I think the fact is this AI,
the great story here is AI is making it easier
for us to build these really useful and helpful tools
that they didn't have,
the ROI didn't exist five years ago.
Right.
The investment cost is so low on these things.
I'm actually, you know, there is a lot of,
and we talked about it like a couple months ago,
there's a lot of, like a lot of AI tools
get sold through mere mongering and the fear mongering.
And it's a valid,
it has been a valid marketing PR technique
for thousands of years.
Again, there's not much new under the sun in that regard.
Like the Silicon Valley, big tech AI boys and men
and people, you know, the public ones,
I'm not gonna name them all,
but you know, the ones who say,
it's gonna come sentience tomorrow.
Five o'clock, it's time.
I am really sorry
that I'm not getting a chance to meet Brent here today
because-
Next time we'll have Brent.
We'll have you back.
We'll have you back with Brent.
Yes, please do.
Because I have questions for him.
What is he doing for Satya?
Does he have access to the frontier labs
with those frontier models?
And I have a question originally coined by Isaac Asimov
for him called the last question.
If there is anything he can tell me from anything he does
because I think he sees scale in what he does there
and he's involved in some things
or you're maybe too humorous about what he does.
No, I don't know what, I mean,
who knows what Brent does?
I don't even know.
He might be that kind of,
you know, in office space
when they sent the guy down to the basement
with the stapler.
That may be Brent for all we know.
I don't know what he actually does
and he talks abstractly about it,
but I think mostly he just does work for Satya.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Well, whatever that is, I feel amiss.
Oh, I could just be making up stories
about what he's doing with Satya.
I don't know.
I don't know what he does.
I feel like you stole a slice of pie
from me today, Brent.
Warning, warning.
Next time you get to meet me.
Let's do it again with Brent
because at that point you'll have more information
to share.
I'm gonna start from there.
It'll be great.
Yes, yes.
And I do have one question for you though.
Okay, I'm ready.
It is just like with me,
it's always a little bit oblique.
I'm a bad person for direct answers.
So it is partially related to that sort of tech,
sort of creativity, but also everything.
Like what is your definition of like discovery, right?
We're talking what's discovery, what's innovation.
What's your relationship with aha moments in life?
How do they come?
How do they go?
Do you know where they come from?
And does it, did it, does the new,
like the most recent oomph AI oomph all that wave
did any change anything about that?
Like the aha moments.
Cause as I'm having some musical experience,
you might know what I'm talking about
when like you said, things connect.
Like you feel sometimes like wires just connect
and the flow flows, right?
So I just want to know your relationship with that
and what do you think about it in general?
Well, great question.
And although I have done a lot of work as a create,
being creative as a musician,
my specialty of my degrees was in a compensation.
That's a new word.
Composition, orchestration.
Composition is very creative.
The orchestration, the arrangement of music
for instruments is almost mathematical, very.
And you can find some cool patterns there.
Like there was some, I can go into stories,
which is really the answer.
My relationship with discovery
is largely through pattern matching.
I see how things go together.
Not always at first.
It's really exciting for me.
This can be, but figuring stuff out about myself
or seeing things in work or seeing things in life
where I can find a new connection
and how two or more things work together.
Those are my aha moments.
They happen when peanut butter gets in my chocolate
for the, or what's a better one.
I'll talk about it abstractly.
It just happens when I think this is a new way
to look at this because I learned looking over here.
This is why I read so much,
because I get new patterns.
I can look at the world in different ways.
I love it.
My big aha moments are when I find a new way
to look at something
because it was something else I learned.
Or I find a way to connect things I didn't know before,
like I said before.
So it's, those are my aha moments.
AI, AI has both helped and hurt.
I mean, if you're talking about just generative AI
in that it can recognize patterns.
It can also make up patterns where they aren't there.
And what's really helped me be successful with AI
is my joy of discernment
and not believing everything it says
or asking, or even asking myself,
why would it come up with this answer?
Is there a better one?
But I, so.
I think that's also critical thinking.
Yeah.
New verbatim saying that I remember.
Cause I think I didn't ask that directly last time,
first and last time we met in person
when we were taking our urban hike.
I think I started poking in that direction a little bit.
And if I irritate you doing that, do let me know.
No, no, no, you don't.
I love thinking about how my brain works.
So we can do a whole episode on this.
May not be exciting for the three listeners,
but I spend, like I told you at the beginning,
I spend a lot of time thinking how my brain works.
So even when I find these patterns,
what's really almost frustrating for me,
and I do have to close here in a little bit,
but when I see a pattern that's so obvious,
sometimes I beat myself up,
like, why the hell didn't I see this pattern earlier?
So that's, and I have to think, okay, why didn't I?
And I really do a lot of analysis on that.
I'm trying to, I feel like my brain is good at braining,
but because I can't always control it,
I need to pay attention to how it brains and hone it.
And I need to teach it to brain better.
It's, and it sounds like you understand
that everybody else may not,
but I do think a lot about how my brain works.
Like what, when my brain does something,
I will ask myself, why?
Why did you even do that sometimes?
Yeah, and for the good things and for the bad things,
too, I think I spend time,
I do a lot of reflection and journaling
and thinking about why does my brain do what it does?
How can I get it to do more of the good things
and less of the bad things?
So just journaling help in general,
well, whether with aha moments or with life,
with doing life.
It does for me because what it is,
is if I get a whole bunch of thoughts in my head,
they will stay there unless I get them out.
Those thoughts in my head,
they create the buzz, the refrigerator buzz,
all these thoughts.
I have to get them out.
So I have to write them down.
Sometimes I type them a lot lately,
I've been writing them by hand.
It helps reduce the buzz if I can get all the ideas
and things in my head out on paper.
And sometimes I go back and reread,
sometimes they don't, but just the act of it's-
The act of-
Figuratively, I am-
Recapitulation of the inner workings.
I am emptying the things out of my head
that are causing buzz.
I feel you.
I feel you, sir.
Kind sir.
I think we sort of connected,
connected a couple of dots in there.
And again, I feel rather weird
talking with the quote unquote,
typical middle of the road,
technical, super hardcore, technical people.
And it's also funny where I find myself
being able to do at least as well
and even more than most prolific engineers
in my immediate surroundings.
Especially now because the good engineers
aren't much better.
And still being a person, you know?
Yeah, that's the important part, be a human.
So what I wanna have you back in,
we'll figure out a time.
There is a whole AI conversation
that I wanna have and involve Brent in.
And it's gonna be fun.
Oh, yes.
We will have to decide your,
we will have to poke in the direction
of figuring out,
like my main question over the day every day
is like, hey, brain, who is the boss in the house today?
We'll lean there.
Yeah, I'm gonna be thinking
about that conversation a lot.
All right, we gotta get going.
This has been part one,
part two, to be determined,
a fantastic time hanging out.
Just, I like the way your brain works.
It's been fun talking with you.
It's pretty funky.
It weirds me out most of the time
when I just let it go.
And once in a while, like you said,
it's like you seem to understand what I'm talking about.
I'm also really glad that we are sort of
on the same wavelength in that regard
as much as it's possible
for two almost entirely strange adults podcasting
about things, all things life and not life.
You know?
All things are life.
All right, thank you again.
This has been A.B. Testing.
We'll see you next time.
Bye-bye.